I always do this Reggie won't you
something go ahead what big bad
experience eres brain it's really
because I don't seem too crazy
what truck
let's just get this out of the way
Delsin is a bit of a turd the guys got
super power so he's not totally
worthless it's just a shame that he
didn't get a powered up personality or
you know fashion sense he's got a real
sour attitude you're gonna have to deal
with it endure his obnoxious
observations and the paper-thin story
he's a part of just relax if miss second
son is too fun to get caught up in the
negativity well we got him right i--i
flush that mean old conduit for you good
job everybody
Delsin was a delinquent who spent his
days spray-painting doodles while
avoiding his brother Reggie who happens
to be a cop and then he got magical
powers with smoke coursing through his
veins that army occupying Seattle
suddenly doesn't seem so scary
of course the anti conduit Crusaders
rounding up all the local mutants aren't
going to let a beanie wearing Punk push
them out of the Pacific Northwest they
have powers of their own concrete powers
which set the stage for impressive
showdowns in this open-world adventure I
am so very disappointed in you the
visuals are amazing with flashy lighting
effects and incredible detail bringing
Seattle the life but the thing that's
going to draw you in is the empowering
movement as a smoke man Delsin can turn
to a wisp shoot up air vents drift
effortlessly from rooftop to rooftop or
dash across the rain-soaked streets as
an ethereal shadow and once you've
properly spooked your enemies unleash a
little hell Chuck flaming missiles of
the heads of the meetings that are
trying to cut you to shreds toss a
grenade to cause everyone to coffin then
finish them off if you're a good guy
shackle them with your smoke handcuffs
if you're an evil jerk light their heads
on fire the choice is yours look out
below
second son has a similar binary morality
system to the previous infamous games
there are a handful of story moments
when you must choose to be super evil or
blindingly good and your crew karma
based on what kind of dull sin you
create it's a flimsy system and though
the story does go to different places
the powers you can unlock don't
appreciable change but there is one
bonus to this black or white morality
system Delsin has a super move no matter
which side of the coin he falls on and
you can only earn it by exterminating
enemies in accordance with your moral
stance if you're a hero precision is key
don't kill any bystanders and make sure
you subtract SCID ently murder anyone
and your precious weapon goes away if
your villain chaos reigns kill anyone
kill everyone but don't stop go too
slowly and your chain counter disappears
these two systems make playing as good
or bad feel remarkably different
I love the methodical thoughtful
conquest as a savior but once I switch
sides I smiled with evil gliese I
destroyed everything in my path it's a
great system that adds a lot more the
second son than the obvious story
choices if you do boo-boo-boo-boo-boo
this fast healing stuff is gonna cover
beauty of second son is the frenetic
combat missions push you to use your
movement to strike down opposing forces
but maybe helicopter soaring in from
above armored vans calling in
reinforcements from below and cement
soldiers zooming all around you so you
dash into the fray lob a few point-blank
missiles and then scamper to safety
there's an exhilarating balance of the
fights
Delsin can die easily so it's y s-- or
generate hell up on the sidelines if
you're a little more aggressive you can
earn that super weapon and kill everyone
in your path
oh so satisfying the explosive fights
find a happy balance between the
methodical encounters of the first
infamous and the overly chaotic
showdowns of infamous to everything in
second son just feels so fine to do you
want nothing more to unload your pent-up
aggression on the entire poppy
still second son feels very familiar
this is not a living breathing world
rather it's just a playground for your
amusement and the bite-size side
missions provide a good reason to take a
break from the bloodshed spray-painting
rebellious graffiti was my favorite
activity I made sure to do everything
possible on both my good and evil
playthrough because I didn't want to
leave this world second son is a
graphical showcase with exceptional
combat but the piece is holding the rest
of this adventure together can't quite
live up to those two amazing elements
you're left with a game that's pure
entertainment that's more concerned with
delivering fun than mixing up a winning
formula second son is a great way to
spend a couple dozen hours just try to
laugh off delsin's annoying chatter
you'll be happier you did this is gonna
be awesome
you